guilty of contempt Joanne frail had been
warned to expect a prison sentence as a
juror she caused the collapse of the
multi-million pound drugs case she was
trying and all because she contacted one
of the defendants Jamie Stewart by
Facebook their discussions using the
modern social networking technology fell
foul of one of our most ancient laws the
integrity of the jury system should be
preserved and protected and whether you
communicate by Facebook whether you
research on the Internet whether you
talk over your garden fence and are
influenced by others you must understand
that when you take an oath as a member
of a jury when you disobey that is or
when you disobey the instructions of the
judge and it is discovered you may very
well be held in contempt using Facebook
the pair discussed details of the case
Joanne said Jamie nice one hon hope you
both sort things out what's happening
with the other charged Seward asked
which yours
no the Class B can't get anyone to go
either
no one budging please don't say anything
cause Jamie they could call mistrial
Jamie Stewart who was given a two month
suspended sentence said she replied in
the heat of the moment after her
acquittal I'm sorry for the woman I
really a seriously though she's a mother
and I see know what sets you running I
felt through the judges conceded it was
Joanne frail who initiated the contact
in sentencing her to eight months in
prison they ruled her conduct in
visiting the Internet repeatedly was
directly contrary to her oath as a juror
and her contact with the acquitted
defendant constituted flagrant breaches
of the orders made by the judge for the
proper conduct of the trial
Joanne frailes lawyer said the mother of
three was devastated at what had
happened and the impact it will have on
her children mrs. Crale does not seek in
any way to diminish the seriousness of
her action
rather she hopes but the example that
has been set in this case will help
prevent any other person undertaking
jury service from acting in the way that
she did judges have been increasingly
concerned about the potential influence
of social networking and the internet on
juries the length of Joanne frail
sentence will no doubt highlight the
risk jurors run if they ignore the law